entre les princesses au galop et l'homme
qui murmurait à l'oreille des chevaux le
percheron est à l'honneur à thiron
gardais une façon de rappeler les
origines de cette race n'est pas
seulement due ça nous permettait en même
temps de rendre hommage à guy mériel qui
était un enfant du pays et qui a été une
des personnes qui a relancé la race
percheronne dans le perche que dans les
années 90 il a vendu des chevaux
percherons euro disney pour les calèches
qui emmène les voyageurs dans le parc et
du coup ça a permis de relancer la race
des calèches il y en a justement
plusieurs pour offrir une balade aux
visiteurs mais ce n'est pas la seule
activité du cheval aujourd'hui il ya le
débardage du bois qui tend à revenir il
ya aussi dans l'agriculture biologique
et les vignes le cheval percheron est
très très employé fin de plus en plus
donc tout ça contribue à
montrer l'utilité et la valeur du cheval
qu'on adore ici mais le nombre
d'élevages de percherons tend à diminuer
dans la région faute de repreneur la
prod relève derrière donc
mais cette france mettre ce conseil à
des personnes qui sont intéressées il
qu'ils sont passionnés c'est pour
valoriser la race et trouver la relève
que l'association cheval percheron a
choisi l'eure et loir pour organiser
cette fête j'ai constaté qu'il y avait
de moins en moins d'éleveurs de chevaux
percherons dans l'eure-et-loir et
et que on voulait faire voir notre
cheval bas surtout le berceau de la
place ni dans l'ordre cette fête devient
en effet itinérante dans tout le perche
en attendant le rendez vous l'an
prochain à la ferté vidame la relève est
en partie trouvé avec cette jeune fille
qui monte à 14 ans en amazone